hey if you could do a joint album with
anybody right now who would it be
um a joint album with anybody
uh i think i ain't gonna lie to be
honest i'm working on some joint albums
already some [ __ ] uh me and grizzly been
locked in do some [ __ ]
me and grizzly got some crazy [ __ ] uh i
want to do a joint with polo me and polo
probably do a joint
um man baby still gonna do our joint
album but if i had to just reach for the
stars man i would
say i
the studio locked in how many records
you guys got so right now we got
uh like five and the polo g herbo
project is
is that something that's actually being
worked on no we me and polo got a lot of
records too though but it ain't even
like it's just a thought for real though
but i think it might you know
[ __ ] might happen that'd be crazy and
then what is this
like we always hear babies not rapping
anymore you know baby
man you know he said he's one of the
most popping executives in the videos
now for to say
on some mogul [ __ ] right now he's on his
mogul [ __ ] we could use another free
crack though you know whatever
show he definitely i want to drag him
out retirement man you know i think he
he gonna he gonna rap though he gonna
put some [ __ ] out for sure because he
still loves music bro people don't even
understand like
the mogul [ __ ] he's on because he don't
i don't think i like about what baby and
what he's been doing the last few years
is like he ain't like bragging about all
the [ __ ] he's involved
no he don't you don't at all you know he
let his work do the talking for him you
know what i'm saying
that's the way he posted he always been
a humble [ __ ] anyway he's not really
feeling like
popping [ __ ] for real like he'd just be
chilling you know like if you know him
you know what he got going on you know
i'm saying um
and i don't think people really realize
like bro really hard as [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] out here that really could rap
better than him he'd just be chilling i
remember seeing him on tour he opened up
for ty dolla sign in like 2000 yeah
15 16. i saw him in austin texas i was
like oh this dude's different yeah no
for real i remember that for sure yeah
yeah now bro he's still like one of the
hardest [ __ ] out right now that he's
just not rapping